[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
two cleveland police officers will not
face federal charges in the shooting
death of twelve-year-old tamir rice
an encounter that helped galvanize the
black lives matter movement
video from the november 2014 incident
shows officer timothy lohmann shooting
rice
seconds after loehmann and officer frank
garnback arrived on scene
rice was holding a pellet gun the
officers say they mistook the toy for a
real gun
we spoke to the boy's mother who says
her son deserves
justice i'm just appalled right now
and disappointed and hurt samaria wright
says the justice department's decision
to not prosecute the officers for her
son tamir rice's death
is inexcusable and unjust i should have
an indictment and a conviction for my 12
year old son
the 2014 shooting was caught on camera
outside a cleveland recreation center
a 9-1-1 caller had alerted police about
a quote guy
pointing a gun at people and said the
person was probably a juvenile
and the gun was probably fake that
information was never transmitted to the
officers who responded
one opened fire on 12-year-old rice
seconds after they arrived
in statements following the shootings
both officers said they thought rice was
pulling out a real gun from his
waistband
and claimed they gave him multiple
commands to show his hands
in a statement tuesday the justice
department said prosecutors found
insufficient evidence to support federal
criminal charges against the officers
they say the video is grainy shot from a
distance adding that tamir's hands are
not visible during the relevant time
it was clear as day to me my son was
scared when they rolled up on him
they didn't even give him a chance to
respond rice's lawyer sabode chandra
says the video tells the whole story
he rushed upon a child got out of the
car and
fired his weapon immediately and you can
tell that from the video
there's no pausing there's no
deliberation there's no calling out
warnings there's nothing
in 2015 a state grand jury also declined
to indict the officers
sparking protests around the country the
rice family
not only have they lost a child which is
bad enough
but they have been deprived of the fair
process time and again
america will never give me no closure
for any other family
that has to go through this if they
don't break this system
officer lowman was fired nearly three
years after rice's death
for lying on his application the family
is demanding more information after an
october new york times report
that doj supervisors denied career
prosecutors
2017 request to use a grand jury to
gather evidence in their investigation
it's just still so hard when you think
about that and seeing that poster
for tamir rice 2022 to 2014.
12 years old that's what i was about to
share 12 years old
you know in 2014 was also when eric
garner was killed in new york
and michael brown in ferguson yeah
really started galvanizing the black
lives matter movement